there is surprising new evidence about
what is fueling the gender gap in
keeping women from top jobs and the
highest earnings the issue is explored
and one of the most emailed articles on
the New York Times website women did
everything right and then work got
greedy that is a reference to how a lot
of employers now demand long in flexible
hours and round-the-clock availability
CBS News contributor Jody canter is an
investigative reporter for The New York
Times whose work prompted the rise of
the need to movement good morning good
morning to you okay so let's define for
everybody what is greedy work greedy
work is a new way of thinking about a
very familiar problem which is how do we
have all of these women going to law
school all of these women going to
business school
it's practically 50/50 in those arenas
and then you look a few years later you
see very few female CEOs very few women
controlling capital really being the
decision-makers what's happening is that
bias is it's sexism this brilliant
article by my colleague Claire Kane
Miller says no there's this other
explanation which is that work hours are
out of control if you really want to be
a super achiever you have to devote
yourself entirely to the workplace you
have to start your week on a Sunday
afternoon or a Sunday evening and
because people are marrying essentially
they're twins one person with an MBA
marries somebody else with an MBA it's
like it only makes sense for one of
those two people to become try to become
the super achiever and it usually ends
up being a man so it's a little bit of a
stomach dropping article because it says
wow you know women have done everything
right and then this other thing came
along the explosion of hours in the
world of work and it's eroding all of
these educational gains
so let's circle the usually becomes the
man who's the one who works the 80 hours
why well that is a great question and
that's kind of the biological drift that
nobody can get away from you know by the
time you have the babies you take the
maternity leave you know is it tradition
is it in our heads etc etc and there are
some exceptions to that we all know
couples where it's women who have taken
the lead and the man has hung back more
but what it's showing us is that there's
this thing that we all feel and that's
felt at all income levels right not just
the elite one which is that work demands
more of us than ever and that is that is
that has a kind of obliterating power
over other things we're trying to do an
address but there really surprised me in
this article it says that working
mothers today spend as much time with
their children as stay-at-home mothers
did in the 70s
yeah parenting has become more demanding
and it's almost become many people treat
it you know sort of like a job I thought
another one of the great lines in this
article was talking about this kind of
class of women
it was saying these women don't stay at
home because their husbands are rich
their husbands are rich because they
stay at home essentially they're the
hidden ingredient that lets their
husband let's their husbands work all
these crazy hours so what's that what
are some of the proposed solutions
well there are proposed solutions but
this is where it's really hard because
we all have the disease of being unable
to draw back from more work and so what
would really take on the one hand
there's a lot of evidence saying that
you know beyond a certain point
working excessively hard actually
doesn't get you anywhere we all know it
it's logical right that beyond a certain
point we're not actually accomplishing
that much more but the effort it takes
either on the part of individuals or
businesses to really draw back and
establish limits it's very hard to do
the workers have to demand it in effect
but who's gonna have the courage to
demand it or workplaces are gonna have
to support it and say there are
workplaces who have said for example no
emails after 6:00 p.m. unless it's
really an emergent of this company news
organization all right Joe they always
good to see you thank you so much Jodi
Kantor thanks